à l'espace autochtone aujourd'hui je
vous propose une incursion dans le monde
de la socam la socam c'est la société de
communication attikameks montagnaise
alors autour de la table beaucoup de
monde bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui donc plusieurs personnes le
directeur général de la sopecam monsieur
florent bégin bonjour monsieur virement
déjà madame hivon monsieur juste un chat
chez vous êtes le président du conseil
d'administration de la socam
mais vous êtes aussi un journaliste et
le directeur de la radio communautaire
de votre communauté vous êtes originaire
d'obedjiwan bonjour bonjour également
une animatrice à la socam
alors vous êtes tania rock et vous vous
en fait tous les jours à la radio vous
parlez en innu à toutes les communautés
innues du québec et du labrador
oui on s'adresse en innu quand qu'on
fait les conférences de presse bayard
presse jeudi
et également les interviews d'accord et
puis le dernier et non le moindre
réjean nekoi dos vous êtes originaire de
manon and one donc vous êtes un
attikameks et vous tous les jours vous
vous adressez à vos auditeurs en
attikameks victimes alors bienvenue à
tous merci d'être là on va parler de la
socam on va parler de l'avenir de la
socam aussi et ça tombe bien parce que
c'est l'année des langues autochtones
l'année internationale des langues
autochtones et en plus c'est le mois des
langues autochtones donc il ya beaucoup
de choses à dire
et en fait monsieur bégin c'est ça le
but de la socam c'est de promouvoir
c'est de faire vivre les langues
autochtones dans votre cas cellino et
latika mec
exactement c'est ça a été le début
premier d'ailleurs que dehors de la
création de la socam il ya 30 ou 35 ans
maintenant c'est est de promouvoir et de
de sauvegarder les langues est ce qu'un
mec innu entre août et d'informer les
populations sur sur ce qui était les
négociations à l'époque qui était sous
l'égide du conseil attikameks montanier
et la création de la socam devenaient
l'outil pour informer les tenir au
courant les populations inouï attikamek
de tout ce qui pouvait se passer du côté
de l'avancement des négociations
territoriales
c'étaient les objectifs de départ et ils
le sont toujours
mais depuis ce temps là on a beaucoup
évolué vous avez évolué mais le nom n'a
pas changé vous n'êtes pas passés de la
socam à la sauque est ok par contre vous
étiez en avance sur votre temps parce
que les langues voulait préserver depuis
longtemps donc il ya déjà depuis
longtemps les efforts ont débuté bien
avant la socam là pour la préservation
des langues ccc des efforts constants
seconde qui se faisait déjà des dents
dans les conseils de bande dans les
milieux autochtone mais la socam est
devenu je dirais un outil privilégié
parce que vous savez que les langues
autochtones sont de transmission orale
avant tout oui donc quel merveilleux
outil qu la radio et s'adresse
s'adressait nous easter et aux anneaux
population en langue autochtone
donc on utilise toujours la langue
vivante la langue orale pour transmettre
l'information transmettent l'actualité
des émissions en langues
encore parler pour l'export des autres
stars alors c'est à vous que je pose la
question parce que vous êtes le
directeur général comment se porte la
socam en 2019 je vous dirai en étant
très honnête l'oas maintient bien on
tient toujours
parce que ce plan financier cdu/csu plan
financier nos budgets on considère ce
considérablement diminué au cours des 15
dernières années et on cherche toujours
à équilibrer nos budgets pour tenter de
consolider l'équipe ici à la socam on
est on est une dizaine de personnes qui
travaillent à la production
l'administration et on tente à chaque
année c'est des efforts constants
constant constant pour tenter de
consolider l'équipe pour permettre à la
socam de continuer d'informer de
continuer sa mission de sauvegarder les
langues et d'informer population aux 10
km ou alors vous avez des gens qui sont
solides qu'ils restent là dans ce cas de
régent un régent vous êtes là depuis
plusieurs années dans quelques jours de
plus dix ans depuis dix ans donc vous
êtes un des anciens de la socam je peux
pas je pense pas que je peux me définis
comme anciens parce qu'on aime qui qui
sont là depuis un bon bout de temps on a
dit on à milhas dallas qui est pas là
aujourd'hui à vos amis dubé donc je suis
dans le milieu maintenant oui c'est vrai
tania vous êtes une jeune de la socam
vous êtes là depuis combien de temps oui
et moi j'arrive récemment depuis
décembre c'est votre comment vous avez
été reçu par la communauté c'est sûr que
la communauté ici à québec où la
communauté la communauté ea nous les
gens à qui vous parlez tous les jours
c'est sûr que moi je réside ici à québec
mais quand je suis revenu dans ma
communauté c'est sûr qu'on me parlait
beaucoup
quand on me dirait on t'écoute à la
radio ont même cette entente puis on
t'écoute souvent avec j'ai eu comme
conscience qu'on m'écoute est quand même
un peu partout où l'on est ce que vous
avez appris
linou grâce aux émissions de la soca
parce que vous êtes jeune on le voit
bien vous n'avez pas 36 ans vous n'avez
pas l'âge de la socam la socam est né
bien avant vous alors est ce que est ce
que quand vous étiez jeune vous étiez l
écoute des émissions produites par
l'asso
c'est sûr que quand j'ai passé mon
entrevue muriel était justement dans la
table et puis je lui ai dit que c'était
la voie qui avaient bercé mon enfance
depuis très longtemps parce qu'elle
était là depuis je pense que depuis 25
ans qui est elle est là
donc à chaque midi on l'a on entendait à
la radio puis on l'entend encore
justement fait que c'est sûr que comme
moi je parle lie nos deux pics jeunes
depuis que mon enfance finalement pu
donc j'aime vraiment ce communiqué en
innu et fleurant vous parlez du new
normal aux vous parlez du québec non
plus ne comprenait pas ce que vous vos
animateurs avoir choisi quelques
quelques quelques éléments mais pas
suffisamment pour pour avoir une
conversation de maîtrise
oui réjean vous le l'amour de la radio
la transmission également c'est arrivé
comment pour vous en fait quand je suis
arrivé ici j'étais aux études à québec
au début et puis bon bain les événements
a mené à ce que j'arrête
puis à ce moment là c'était un arrêt
temporaire des études je me suis
retrouvé à la socam 10 et 20 postes qui
s'était libérée donc depuis dix ans je
suis ici puis la radio mais par contre à
la radio il est déjà travaillé le jeune
en tant qu'étudiant à man wan dans la
radio locale louis donc je peux dire que
c'est pas quelque chose qui je pense est
plus jeune que j'allais pas plupart mais
la vie m'a amené à travailler ici donc
alors vous desservez trois communautés
les trois communauté attikamek la
réception aller comment comment ça se
passe avec les gens il ya un contact
oui oui et puis il faudrait parce que je
pensais à 7 ans tôt il faut le dire
aussi je pense en habitant en ville nous
autres c'est un privilège et je me vois
ça comme un privilège de pouvoir
travailler dans
lang à tous les jours et puis pour ta
question oui effectivement il ya un
contact qui les gens nous le ferons
savoir quand on l'y voit une personne
c'est toi qu'on entend mais je sais une
conversation là où il ya un milieu chez
nous comme un macho yat il ya une radio
communautaire
nous on dessert les deux les deux
nations parce qu'il faut comprendre
qu'il ya deux et deux émissions par jour
les missions du québec et les missions
et nous le chesnois m'acheter wyatt
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de disques emi
qui sont en transition soit pour les
services hospitaliers ou et services
gouvernementaux tout soit donc ça et
même il ya eu des alliances soit il ya
eu des mariages du québec et nous il ya
beaucoup de tickets mecs qui sont dans
les environs de roberval mashteuiatsh
donc on nous on est une des seules
stations je pense là à travers les
lignes douces où on ouvre la switch
redire là pour les émissions 10 km pour
que les attikameks de notre coin oui
entendre leurs émissions d'accord alors
les attikameks juste à vous les
connaissez puisque vous êtes d'obedjiwan
et vous même et là c'est intéressant
parce que autant vous êtes le président
du conseil d'administration de la socam
autant vous même vous êtes dans une des
radios communautaires qui reçoit la
sodam dont vous avez un peu le le double
rôle finalement je pense que je porte
beaucoup de chapeaux et de démêlés de
son pied moi je travaille radio belge
wannes puis on travaille tous ensemble
de la socam ont collaboré ensemble je
travaille beaucoup avec les gens
en partant des informations c'est ce qui
fait qu'on est un réseau même au temps
les gens partagent l'approbation en moi
en pis on se met tous ensemble oui mais
en tant que président de la socam vous
attendez quoi de la socan et m'ont dit
je pense que ça fait ça quand même des
années celui-ci dans le conseil
d'administration qui a tant que
présidente joly était du genre mais pose
ses pieds les a pas reconnus c'est
toujours c'est toujours là ni même pas
les mêmes attentes mais c'est plus haut
niveau la force du des blocs de
développement d'assaut 15 on essaie
d'aller chercher son bond comme tanya
existait une jeune harry gens que tu
encore ici guillaume nous autres nous
attendent par rapport à soucier de
donner les services aux outils temps ça
c'est une chose qu'il vient souvent des
commentaires quant au cycle et jean les
autres stoll il aimerait savoir des
nouvelles locales de leur communauté
et puis entente hawtai ont fait des
efforts dans ce sens l'homme il ya
toujours il faut continuer là parce que
c'est difficile déjà d'avoir des
nouvelles de la communauté soit que soit
qu'il y mettant les gens des radios
locales
ils savent ce qui se passe dans les
communautés mais pour les autres si
c'est comme c'est normal que ça se passe
plus on réussit pas une morale c'est ça
que je faisais alors qu'il ya plein
d'affaires contenu amener un an que
c'est une nouvelle danse a pu être ça
peut être c'est pas obligé d'être là la
grosse affaire c'est dans ce sens là
justement de quoi vous parler parce que
moi j'écoute la radio je peux pas vous
comprendre tania de quoi vous parlez
dans vos émissions
moi je n'assure plus les événements
vraiment les événements qui va avoir
dans les communautés où qui va assurer
des services pour les autochtones donc
s'achever le fil d'actualités puis quand
je fais des bonds événements qui
pourraient intéresser les autochtones
qui pourrait s'inscrire et pouvoir
voyager partager leurs opinions piste à
rassembler pour faire des projets donc
c'est vraiment plus dans cette optique
loc
je fais mais entre nous et donc il ya
des entrevues est ce qu'il ya des lignes
ouvertes
qu'est ce que les gens peuvent
s'adresser à vous vous je sais pas vous
parler de ce qui se passe dans leur
communauté
oui c'est sûr quand on est ouvert aux
lignes ouvertes si jamais un des
personnages va s'adresser pour parler
des sujets qui qui veulent partager
oui très gens vous oui allez vous dire
aussi c'est la socam si je fais un peu
le parallèle avec radio canada par
exemple à radio-canada la maison mère
maria et les stations régionales des
maisons régionales
on marche un peu de la même façon la
socam on est basé ici à québec et nous
c'est pour vous rien qu'on est basée à
québec parce qu'on est proche des
gouvernements on est proche des
événements ici plus plus nationaux en
geek ici à l'assemblée des ja
l'assemblée des chefs du québec et du
labrador dans les bureaux des
commissions de santé services sociaux
l'emploi etc des grandes organisations
qui touche les services des autochtones
donc nous on essaie le plus possible de
toucher à l'actualité dite nationale ce
qui est espionné qui sont d'intérêt
national pour les premières nations
on voit même jusqu'à couvrir des fois de
temps à autre l'assemblée des premières
nations du canada lorsque lorsque
nécessaire au caire et le plus possible
on laisse aux locales le soin d'eux
de couvrir l'actualité locale ou
régionale dans leur coin mais on essaie
de beaucoup de développer ce qu'on a
cette phase qui est pas toujours évident
c'est de travailler beaucoup
le bi directionnelle pas toujours
travaillé dans rouen boos mais de
travailler avec nos stations vers chez
nous aussi de couvrir ses actualités là
et même ce qu'on envisage éventuellement
lorsque ces choses là fonction de long
bien cette travail à l'horizontale aussi
d'une station à l'autre qu'une station
exemple au but johann pourrait être un
lien directionnelle avec une station de
m'acheter williams ou de houe de la
côte-nord moquer justement parlons-en
d'obedjiwan je pense que déjà il ya
beaucoup de nouveautés qui s'en vient
une nouvelle citation qu'est ce qui va
se passer exactement obedjiwan entrevoit
déjà depuis quelques années dans ce
dossier long parce que quand on le garde
les radios communautaires lorca repose
chez nous mais à travailler à travers le
québec
côté désuet la boxe c'est désuet des
équipements sont désuets ccl2 quand même
d'aller chercher du financement québec
au canada
on n'a pas accès mais c'est bien on ira
bien si vous avez doublé
ouais c'est encore trop peu et on essaie
quand même de se développer par nos
hôtes peine commencé que les reds
communautés sont indépendants de la
socam à landreau propres considérations
nos propres projets puis on est en effet
en hausse et d'après ce qu'on peut nous
on se projette botte c'est ce qu'on est
en train de faire maillet commune des
deux appareils doxa c'est bien c'est pas
bien pensé et puis on travaille dessus
ok mais j'imagine que les défis sont
encore plus grands que juste un nouveau
bâtiment j d'une valve équipements je
suppose de parler de donne de nouvelles
bâtiment tout
dossier à monter des plans d'affaires
puis est ce si c'est un gros travail non
mais il ya d'autres réseaux leurs canaux
six ans quand démarche aussi de faire le
même le même type de projet oui alors
réjean vous donc de votre côté vous
arrosez obedjiwan manawan donc les trois
communauté attikamek en fait qu'est ce
que les auditeurs attendent de vous
c'est quoi ce qu' ils s'attendent à ce
qu'ils attendent de n'importe quelle
station de radio de la qualité des
sujets qui les touchent
et puis si ça qu'on essaie d'amener dans
nos émissions
mais encore une fois comme je disais
tantôt il ya une fois c'est pas évident
mais on travaille fort on travaille fort
dans ce sens là et puis la langue aussi
très important dans la langue je pense
que à part la socam il n'y a pas
beaucoup de de dot endroit où est ce que
les gens peuvent à tous les jours à les
écouter des des nouvelles ou la musique
dans la langue qu'ils puis la socam je
pense que c'est aussi ça sa mission est
de promouvoir la langue entre
l'expliquer ils s'attendent ils
s'attendent aussi souvent ce que je me
fais ils s'attendent à ce qu'on a ce
qu'on pille et on est loin d'être des
experts dans la langue dans nos langues
respectives et reprendre aussi parfois
c'est bien c'est bien qu'ils nous
appellent puis qu'ils nous disent où à
vis du sommet il y aurait fallu le dire
autrement donc c'est ça qu'on veut aussi
le sacré un un espèce de deux
rapprochements la même temps c'est parce
que si on a comme une petite différence
de deux dialectes au chevet de joie des
dépôts n'utilise pas le même monde que
je parle je vous parlais avec rue jean
louis benoit pauvres aux biens dont il
ya des mots qui sont plus utilisés à ce
qu'ils essaient handique nolin ghz
de la forêt et puis de moins en moins
les gens vont dans des forêts fait qu'il
ya beaucoup de mots apparemment que qui
existe qui conte les utilisons souvent
d'une chimie noir c'est ça les mots moi
je les entends souvent quand j'ai co
design vraiment des années 80 85 par des
aînés oui des fois des mots que
j'entends leur jeu s'est même posé que
ce que je vois une personne qui
travaille sur la langue
c'est ce que ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui simulant les tullistes plus
demandés justement si j'avais appris ma
langue ici à la socam je t'avais dit que
je l' ai appris depuis que je suis jeune
mais je te dirait vraiment que
j'apprends toujours un peu plus chaque
jour commun ils disent des fois on a des
appels pcd hinault reprennent pour dire
correctement le mot puis j'ai bien aimé
ça tu m'avais demandé si j'avais en lien
avec les auditeurs j'ai pas encore eu la
chance mais on a fait la tournée ils
n'ont justement la semaine passée qui
m'a donné la chance d'aller voir
justement les autochtones sur place et
j'ai justement il ya certaines personnes
qui m'ont repris pour des mollahs puis
j'étais super content parce que
justement c'est ce qu'on va faire on
veut faire vivre la langue s'il faut la
faire revivre pour la faire revivre
évidemment oui
alors là c'est intéressant qu'on arrive
sur ce sujet là parce que je voulais y
venir c'est ça vous êtes sorti je le
disais c'est l'année des langues
autochtones c'est aussi le mois des
langues autochtones et donc vous êtes
parti en région
watania tu es parti réjean je dis tu
voues bon vous allez partir la semaine
prochaine à mais rappelons ce qui s'est
passé ou est-ce que vous êtes allé la
semaine dernière la semaine dernière on
a fait la tournée ils n'ont pour
justement le mois des langues
internationales autochtone et c'est ça
la première journée on a été investie
cette baisse qui dessert aussi justement
la sauvegarde du patrimoine et de la
culture et des langues
l'institut est où un maillot amarillo
tenable à saint gilles waes et ils
puissent se rencontrer les directeurs et
ce qu'ils font revivre les langues dans
cette institution la deuxième journée on
était allé à l'école touche technique et
une école primaire où on a rencontré
aussi les directeurs et les professeurs
en langue ils n'ont et on eu la chance
de côtoyer des jeunes qui avaient
préparé une chanson en ligne nous et il
était tout habillé dans un habit
traditionnel et justement partager une
recette que d'une grande fait que la
dernière journée on a on s'est déplacé
pour aller avec windjet à la maison de
la culture ou encore une fois on a
rencontré les conseillers les directeurs
des programmes en éducation erlang et on
a vraiment apprécié notre séjour à les
faire le tour rencontrer les auditeurs
et puis voir le pouls de toutes les wii
les communautés oui mais là c'est le fun
parce que de maigres
oui c'est ça pour le savoir puisque ce
qui est important de savoir là dedans
c'est que lorsqu'ils se sont déplacés ça
a été des émissions indirectes pressés
se sont installés là avec aujourd'hui
avec équipement qui est assez assez
léger maintenant les comores ex on peut
faire des émissions en direct et les
toute l'équipe s'est déplacée la boc
peau diffusé en direct directement de
machettes mais le tannat mais hélas ce
qui est formidable c'est que vous
rencontrez évidemment les aînés à ceux
qui qui les gardiens de la langue mais
vous rencontrer aussi les jeunes ceux
qui vont prendre la relève ceux qui
veulent apprendre la langue est ce que
vous l'avez senti avec les jeunes que
vous avez rencontrées qui avaient un
intérêt pour continuer à parler linou
c'est ce que quand on a été voir les
jeunes on le voyait dans leurs yeux leur
coeur qu'il était fier de le deuil par
les lignes nous et je pense que c'est
vraiment un enjeu important de le faire
revivre
et c'est ça n'en tient qu'à nous
pourquoi faire justement sauvegarde et
c'est cette tradition la culture et la
langue alors dans le cadre de ce mois de
l'histoire n'ont pas de l'histoire mais
deux des langues autochtones
réjean vous partez vous la semaine
prochaine effectivement nous autres
c'est un peu dans le même sens qui est
l'équipe qui nous en fait nous autres on
va aller au conseil de la nation du
québec qui se trouvait là dessus que oui
après ça on va là où et moi chier le
land
même le surlendemain un manhwa et vous
avez prévu quoique en activité en fait
comme vous le mentionnez cfi je pense
qu'on l'a même pas mentionné je pense
est important de dire si dans le cadre
d'un projet que la socam travaille
dessus cette année avec les initiatives
des langues autochtones du hainaut
fédéral on avait présenté un projet qui
s'appelle cap d'agde est donc ici dans
ce cadre là aussi qu'on voit dans ces
communautés
donc pour ce qui est de la dessus qu'on
va les rencontrer les gens là bas
le grand chef entre autres qui va qui va
venir participer à notre émission
constant a enrichi son stand by puis on
lire merci d'abord parce qu'elle a boy à
l'institut linguistique attikameks il ya
des personnes qui travaillent là dedans
et puis il nous est souvent un item qui
sont au moins parce qu'il ya des
nouveautés qui qui existait pas de la
force et donc c'est aux autres qu'ils
voyent à ce qu on sait la langue est
vivante le long terme et donc il nous
est souvent il va voir des personnes de
ceux de l'institut linguistique
attikameks nicole petit coin pour ne pas
le nommer beaucoup qui nous aident donc
si ça des gens là bas qui vont nous
parler de l'importance de la langue dans
le milieu de travail parce qu'on nous
dit souvent aussi la nation du québec
qui a eu des recherches par le passé
c'est une langue très vivant d'un au
dessus de 95% chez j poli chiffres
exacts qui parle encore l'iman de la
nation mais il faut le garder un il faut
pas ça si tu nous lis ce que nous autres
ce patronat du québec un manoir on se
parle en bourse tandis que make jamais
pensé contrairement à la dic est un mec
là moi ce que j'ai constaté à lors de
notre tournée in all
plus on s'éloigne du nord le plus on
perd nos landes
parce que angie tu l'as j'entendais les
jeunes se parlaient en lino pis j'ai
demandé aussi à la prof de l'un est ce
qu'ils se comprennent et ce qui se passe
à charger en innu il m'a dit oui
un maillot ça devient encore un peu
moins pis là même à pessamit que les
jeunes se parlent en français
oh et plus tu t'éloignes du nord plus la
perte de la langue est significatif plus
on se rapproche des grands centres avec
des villes
oui je veux terminer ma réponse parce
qu'il vaut poesy qu'est-ce qu'on allait
aller faire quand votre rente à wemotaci
on va aller à l'école primaire là bas
donc là on va encore une fois invité le
chef de la communauté qui a accepté
d'ailleurs de venir nous voir et puis
les gens qui travaillent à l'école puis
des jeunes aussi on tient à parler aux
jeunes ils puissent encore encore encore
une fois quand je vous disais que la
langue est très vivante c'est bon des
fois moi je me disais c'est bon des fois
de celle du notre langue est vivant il
faut la maintenir vivante et puis c'est
bon de se dire la même chose à l'école
secondaire
oui oui vous allez vous n'allez pas
visité une tentation vous n'allez pas
sous une tension vendredi
c'est un projet qu'on avait on n'a pas
encore de confirmation parce que si on
peut pas dire à telle date
on va aller là ça dépend toujours de la
tête c'est sûr que pour que la sève
colons et gazière la météo soit avec eux
on peut pas on peut pas encore dire si
on va le faire au nom mais on aimerait
ça ah oui et on va le faire car
tassez-vous quoi ah bah oui vous justin
de votre côté à la radio locale
d'obedjiwan vous parlez à vos auditeurs
en attique à mettre tout le temps
toujours au toujours un disque à main
que nous aurons posé 89.9 pour ça et
quand même c'est un pur sang humain
comme il sait socam on a souvent bien
des intervenants corps soit cancon qu'on
parle qu'on ne devrait pas dépenser
il ya toujours une traduction qui vient
naples est d'accord ok alors ça le
service de traduction c'est ce qu'offre
aussi la socam et elle offre également
le gala taken on va en parler dans
quelques instants avant de parler du
gala parce qu'il approche bientôt que je
pense qu'il ya plein de choses à dire
quels sont les grands défis pour vous
cette année
avec la socam c'est le financement cc
c'est le financement c'est toujours le
financement parce que les ressources
sont là c'est un c'est un défi constant
de de trouver le financement nécessaire
pour maintenir nos opérations d autre
défi est important c'est la formation
des ressources humaines la formation de
la relève même si les gens sont ici sont
jeunes il faut comprendre que la plupart
des gens qui viennent qui travaillent
dans nos stations ou qui viennent
travailler ici à la socam noms ont plus
ou moins de formation radio ils
apprennent sur le tas
les jeunes c'est beaucoup plus facile
parce que la technologie les audiences
orient sont facilement facile de comme
un ami comme augustin kaki tout jeune la
régie pour lui smith et c'est très
facile mais donc apprennent beaucoup sur
le tome et toutes les notions de
journalisme de da proche de reportages
que cette erreur ils ont pas
nécessairement ce bagage là ils
l'apprennent sur le terrain mais on
donne on est en partenariat avec radio
canada et avec radio canada on a on en a
donné le depuis les deux dernières
années je pense que c'est sûr on a fait
des petits séminaires de trois jours
pour avec notre équipe ici pour essayer
de voir comment on devrait travailler
les techniques d'entrevue la façon de
monter des émissions etc
donc soit on travaille ça puis on veut
exporter cette petite formation lot un
peu partout en région pour que ce soit
accessible aussi aux gens de la basse
côte nord puis
celle du côté des attikameks également
donc la formation des ressources
humaines ça c'est un élément important
un autre élément important qu'on
discutait lors du colloque qu'on a tenu
au mois de février aussi avec les
stations c'est tout l'aspect de la mise
à niveau de nos de nos stations locales
ce qu'on appelle nous ce que j'appelle
moi le projet d'immobilisation et de
hoëdic radiophonique à lorsque second
juste a parlé tout à l'heure
exactement est ce que la plupart de nos
stations
118 sont son père au goût du jour
les équipements fournis ouvrir toutes
les équipements au complet pour la
plupart il ya quelques stations qui se
sont se sont serré les coudes et qui ont
réussi à s'équiper de deux nouveaux
bâtiments et de nouveaux équipements
comme schefferville m'a dit que mon
coach john on à en acheter wyatt sccv
qui fait d'eux un look à sa nouvelle
station au but jour en temps un travail
est la sienne je sais que man one est
aussi en train de travailler nous aussi
pessamit est en train de s'y donc nous
on n'est pas là pour la socam on n'est
pas là pour faire le travail à leur
place mais on est là pour les soutenir
on est là pour ouvrir des portes
montez le plan d'immobilisations plus
d'essayer de travailler fort pour aller
chercher les supports que ces stations
là puisse voir un jour leur projet se
réalise et inquiet je le disais vous
vous occupez du gala de la socan
s'occupe du gala terwingen pourquoi
c'est la socan qui s'occupe de ce gala
grosse question oui la musique dans une
rentrée ça a besoin de musique
absolument donc l'égalité ou egan
c'était ça a été mis sur pied d'un
instrument premièrement de reconnaître
les artistes c'est une chose est de
faire en sorte que les artistes puissent
plus créer de nouvelles musiques des
nouveaux genres musicaux parce qu'il ya
plusieurs genres musicaux dans le monde
et de lisser les autochtones aussi je
les engueule aujourd'hui être rapide du
cm
il ya dit même techno donc
il ya des autochtones qui les jeunes
autochtones maintenant qui s'adonnent à
toutes sortes de genres musicaux et
c'est bon de promouvoir sa note
intéressante parce que ça vient ça vient
alimenter nos bibliothèques musicales
on sait qu'on connaît florent voilà on
le connaît on connaît elisapie on
connaît ça mian mais on veut en
connaître d'autres
on veut qu'ils aient d'autres jeunes qui
qui qui puisse aussi s'élever au niveau
musical en faisant un gala dans un cadre
professionnel
dans un cas d écoute là on a tenu le
gala la dernière fois au palais montcalm
la première fois s'arrêter au capitole
de québec la première phase est en 2011
à 1,2 million à québec pour la deuxième
fois en 2018 à québec en 2010 2017 jean
louis c'est vrai c'est vrai en 2010 se
tient au palais montcalm l'année
prochaine c'est à trois rivières la
salle
cette année je donne cet automne l'année
prochaine parce que moi je suis toujours
rendu de l'année puis c'est ça ça va se
faire à trois rivières pour mettre à
rivière parce qu'on a décidé de rendre
le gallo isner on a le prenais deux
régions région va se rapprocher des
endroits mal oui on va se rapprocher des
ddd région où sont les autochtones a
créé pour que
les gens puissent participer davantage à
cet événement puis je sais pas si vous
avez mais pour les jeunes de se
retrouver sur une scène comme palais
montcalm de se retrouver sur une scène
comme il va y avoir la salle j antonio
thompson c'est extraordinaire pour eux
le sont obligés de faire les petites
salles ou les mariages ou les les parois
d'un quizz non autochtone vous suivent
est ce qu'ils vont voir les jeunes sur
les sur la scène de bruit de notre comme
tant mieux on ne voit alors le gala
c'est ces différentes catégories
d'artistes c'est ça ouais il ya du faux
et du western du traditionnel il ya du
country du blues du jeu du rap
de techno ça peut aller même jusqu'à au
classique c'est donc là c'est le moment
est ce que c'est le moment pour tous
ceux qui veulent y participer de
s'inscrire comment savoir si un
appartement on a un cahier de mise en
candidature qu'ont annoncé le 5 février
les périodes de candidatures sont
ouvertes jusqu'au 9 où une foule c'est
la dernière journée où les artistes
pourront déposer leur candidature on
demande pas nous à la différence de
l'adisq là non on demande pas
nécessairement un album on demande
environ 5 bonnes pièces hockey sur
lequel ils vont être jugés ça peut se
tenir sur une clé usb peu important et
c'est avec ces pièces là qu'on va juger
des artistes le seul endroit où on
demande un album ben c'est pour la
catégorie meilleur album là on n'a pas
le choix c'est tant mieux c'est les
artistes sont des albums mais on
n'oblige pas les rc samer des albums
parce que ça coûte cher les albums ça
coûte cher alain studio enregistrer
c'est pas tous les artistes qui peuvent
se payer ça de là l'idée de poésie j'ai
nécessairement un album mais
éventuellement plus ça va évoluer plus
les artistes vont performer pluies vont
faire des spectacles plus ils vont
devenir millionnaire et plus ils vont
pouvoir aller en studio et là vous me
disiez évidemment c'est une façon de
faire connaître les jeunes vous avez
quand même miser sur une valeur sûre
c'est sylvie bernard je pense qu'ils
aient la présidente du jury ch de
bernanke et la présidente jury et c'est
sag et ottawa qui est aussi mange julie
salgues et qui a quand même fait son
bout de chemin dans le domaine de la
musique quand il est bien connu et on a
aussi dan bigras cette année là parce
qu'on veut toujours agencé
le jury pour qu'ils soient pas
strictement autochtone mais d'avoir un
oeil extérieur sur la musique et danse
bigras cette année va faire partie comme
membre du jury cette année
voilà puis donc le gala aura lieu au
mois d'octobre le 2 octobre
exemple dans vos émissions que ce soit
en innu en attikameks est ce que vous
vous présenter les artistes autochtones
est ce qu'il ya beaucoup de musique
si tu parle beaucoup mais ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de musique oui c'est ce qu'on
essaie de mettre de la musique
autochtone plus précisément pourquoi la
diffusion il nous oui mais c'est ce
qu'on on essaie aussi de présenter les
artistes autochtones qui y font aussi
partie du canada commencé bien oui bien
sûr oui c'est vrai mais nous avec moi et
nous la différence c'est que on n'a en
aucun cas par jour sans émission
démission réseau dans les deux langues
là dans les deux heures et demie nous
deux heures et le médicament et il ya
tellement de contenu qu'on n'a pas le
temps nécessairement on souhaiterait
mettre plus de musique on souhaiterait
mettre plus de faire des émissions
musicales en éclats musicale mais il ya
tellement de contenu le bulletin de
nouvelles
les les émissions captées ricane qu'on
est en train de faire avec
il s'attire des langues autochtones on a
des capsules en électronique le contenu
il traiterait est entré dedans qui ça
laisse pas beaucoup de place à la
musique mais on tente de faire un peu de
place à la musique et éventuellement on
regarde la possibilité de dans le cadre
justement du projet initial de langue
autochtone de faire des propos retrait
d'artistes autochtones n'est pas très le
musical
justement il parle de contenu lui c'est
quand il ya des artistes qui vont aller
faire des événements comme je vous ai
dit que j'allais plus dans l'optique
d'événements oui là par exemple je
communique avec ces artistes là pour qui
parle justement de leur carrière de leur
avancement invité les auditeurs à se
présenter pour les événements mais que
c'était vraiment plus dans cette optique
là aussi qu'on on essaie de faire
connaître les artistes lui offrir une
visibilité
on a déjà fait des portraits des
artistes qui venaient de sortir un
nouvel album
donc c'est déjà arrivé que qu'on les
appelle et puis qu'on présente l'album
des voix chanson par chanson et en même
temps qui parle de match quand les
complices les canettes prise
donc oui on fait on fait mais j'aimerais
ça parce que j'étais coûtait c'est vrai
qu'on diffuse cinq heures par jour dans
l'ic dans les radios locales
mais en dehors de ce teaser la nôtre
amyot du style qu'il allait jusqu'à y
met des tonnes des chansons
en langue autochtone donc les gens sans
nécessairement passer par la radio
locale et peuvent aller directement sur
le site web de la socan
on entendit ton attaque tonnes ha oui
d'accord donc n'importe qui peut se
brancher n'importe quand sur le site web
en fait et à les écouter le contenu de
la socam ce qui est diffusé sur les
radios communautaires est entendue sur
le site internet mais en plus donc vous
pouvez rajouter du contenu nullement peu
à l'écouté mais comme même si on n'est
pas dans un tome nous y voilà
justin voulait les talents locaux
voulaient fait entendre aussi à la votre
radio communautaire bah oui le plus
souvent possible c'est un peu plus jouir
mais qui met justement on parle d'art
chez nous que ça pas comment enfin le
chercher du financement qui s'appelle
deux artistes que j'aime beaucoup
d'ailleurs on sort du studio tpo les
années aux gâteaux et bien entier c'est
pour ces biens
mais chez nous on fait plus jouer des
artistes autochtones que peu importe qui
nous reçoit dans un autre nation parce
que tu as on en veut créer la visibilité
chez nous on n'y coupe pas juste la
radio belge wannes chez nos mains on
peut l'écouter ou c'est bien terne
oui alors on va faire un dernier tour de
table et je vous demandais à chacun ce
que vous espérez de la socam dans les
années à venir on va commencer peut-être
par le président du conseil
d'administration justin je pense que moi
non ce que je m'attends la socan complot
khaled les problèmes qu'on vit depuis
depuis quelques années les gouvernements
les bailleurs de fonds et c'était qu'on
arrive à une entente soit 5 1 3 1
c'est pour pas qu'on attend toujours
trois quatre mois après que l'un est
financée commencé tard on sait jamais on
sait jamais combien ce qu'on va savoir
on note l écriture d toujours là parce
que nous on est là on y responsables de
son camp puis on a toujours cette
inquiétude on sait pas toujours comment
jongler des barons on est en mode
attente commence vraiment aujourd'hui on
est en mode a tant pis nous ce qu'on
veut aussi que ce soit stam exane et
donc de la stabilité samedi comme en
attikameks stabilité des mots il ya des
mots qu'on peut pas en parler on
pourrait essayer mais ça prendrait un
peu tabou
voilà réjean maintenant vous alors c'est
quoi c'est quoi vos attentes vos espoirs
pour la soirée n'est ce pas que la socam
va demeurer un corps en premier lieu
j'espère qu'il va être là encore pauvre
donnant de nombreuses années et puis
justement il ya une grande dame l'autre
jour au colloque qui nous l'a fait
savoir madame isabelle plénat choi de du
labrador
donc je pense que c'est important que la
socam damart mais aussi il faut le
développer faut qu'ils avouent qu'ils
deviennent maya puis travailler un peu
plus ce souci avec lui encore une fois
avec les radios locales
ça devrait attuli jour là tous les jours
on devrait être en contact avec paul pas
juste quelques fois par semaine ça tous
les jours on devrait s'échanger un peu
plus parler un peu plus non mais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut qu est-ce qu on
peut courir aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe qui est plus de l'état interaction
une interaction donc c'est ça qui est
moins j'espère que ça va ça va se
développer là dans les prochaines années
mais là maintenant au tour de tania oui
justement je vais continuer avec ce
qu'ils y la socam c'est un réseau très
bien établi je pense que ça serait le
fun de travailler plus en interaction
puis vraiment plus avec les communautés
autochtones et j'aimerais vraiment ça
puis c'est sûr qu'on puisse continuer à
faire la sauvegarde de la langue
et le mot de la fin pour florent moi
c'est le sait la mise à jour c'est la
mise à niveau de toutes les stations
locales avoir un réseau vraiment stable
vraiment
mis à jour au niveau des équipements
mais des équipements ça prend des
opérateurs ça prend des animateurs ça
prend des journalistes ce plan des
administrateurs aussi parce que pour
bien fonctionner une radio c'est à pau
un bon directeur c'est après un bond
coordonnateur pour rassurer les bonnes
opérations financières ressources
humaines une radio ça pourrait pas durer
donc à mon niveau je pense que toute la
question de stabilité au niveau local
d'avoir des stations convenable pour
opérer c'est ce que j'espère dans les
quatre cinq six prochaines années et
d'avoir le financement adéquat pour pour
opérer et la formation des ressources
humaines plus financière exactement mais
la formation des ressources humaines
aussi on travaille fort on est enfin
travailler fort encore une fois pour
tenter de faire en sorte qu'ils aient un
programme spécifique pour la formation
des des gens qui travaillent en réduit
autochtone et en argent pierres
oui mais c'est pas tous les autochtones
que c'est très difficile de rentrer
frontières un noël très contingentés
première main et les critères
d'admissibilité sont très centré sont
très élevés ce qui est pas à la portée
de tous les autochtones donc il ya
quelques autochtones qui ont passé par
voir mais c'est pour c'est pas tout le
monde mais justement qui en a a fait une
entente avec le cégep de ses prières
c'est offrir une formation cet automne
justement selon les réalités les des
autochtones souhaitent probablement
moins contingent alors j'espère que vous
souhaitent seront entendus et que la
relève est assurée longue vie à la soca
merci à vous tous de nous avoir reçus
chez vous ici à la socam dans vos
bureaux à wendake et bonne chance pour
la suite et merci merci à tania merci à
florent merci à réjean vous et merci à
justin et la semaine prochaine je vous
invite à être des nôtres pour un autre
facebook qui sera live celui là puisque
celui ci est enregistrée on est le
jeudi 21 mars la semaine prochaine on va
s'intéresser à l' architecture
autochtone et vous allez voir il ya des
choses passionnantes à raconter
merci beaucoup à bientôt